you were afraid of your life and the
potential of getting rape yeah who did
you talk to about the incident
no one isn't that I never talked about
it till this book and even today when
people are asking you you ever
experienced this I've been saying no all
the men that I've worked with and
television have been really respectful
towards me and I had forgotten about
this horrible thing I think we blunt and
repressed bad memories I need the money
so bad and my little boy had been run
over by a car
and I I had no insurance the woman who
ran over him had no insurance his father
had no insurance I had $20,000 worth of
doctor bills I said I don't have any
money would you have to check I said oh
you do not want my check and well you
can't take him out and I said well then
he's going to have to live here because
I don't have $20,000 so this trip to
Mexico was $1500 it was a start and you
just have to go you know wear a bikini
and take you know brochure pictures and
got into a rickety plane and flew down
there and I'm now suddenly going oh I am
so unsafe I'm with three guys and the
first night we get there in a villa
they're all drinking and there's this
creepy guy who works at the villa I was
afraid I just wanted to get this job
done and get the pictures taken get back
home and all of a sudden this creepy
guys there and he's stoned and drunk and
he you want some weed I'm going no I
don't want and I don't want anything and
then he you know lunges towards me and
really tries to like go after me and I
ran cuz he was so drunk and I pushed him
away man now I'm in a house I don't know
if there's they left I'm in this house
and I'm hiding behind a wall and he's
going soon Oh Susan like the worst
horror film and I thought I am if I run
to the ocean he might kill me and no one
will ever know and no one will ever know
where what happened to me and so what I
learned later writing it was the
awfulness of powerlessness
I was completely powerless but I can't
believe you kept it to yourself all was
yours it was pretty pretty hairy he was
and what was your dealt with it
afterwards no and then it's today's
world you would but what some young
mother
do ya what are you supposed to do and I
was too proud to take any welfare
probably I never took anything from
anybody I had an Irish father said don't
take nothing from nobodies
I made the mess of my life and I'm the
one with the baby and I'm gonna I'm
gonna work this all out and I did and he
turned out great
what did you learn from yourself writing
this book I was really proud of us yeah
in adversity and how we come together
and how we've made every problem become
an opportunity we're always together
it's a figure-eight it never begins it
never ends it's love life family sex
business love life family sex and
business I dedicated my book to my two
therapists in my life because yeah I
mean to like set myself straight yeah
she said when you argue and you start
any sentence with you always you never
or you should what do you do you back
the other person in a corner who's gonna
then go well you always you never and
you should the right way to argue
according to therapy is you know when
you do that it makes me feel and then
fill in the blanks you know what the
other person says I didn't mean to do
that now the now it's over it's like
it's a simple little thing so we don't
argue
we never argue anymore we did yes and
sorry those are the two things have to
teach money yes that is actually the key
to a very successful long relationship